six one seven eight three zero four
seven five zero hearing from people a
lot of different thoughts about the
election just a lot of different things
on people's minds who's on the phone
with me now what's your name and where
are you calling from hi David it's
please from Los Angeles California
yeah my question to you will technically
it still them I'm a big fan of also you
in a second cycle pal and our colleges
put a tweet saying Donald Trump had a
sixty-three percent unfavorable during
the general election so my question one
of my first questions is could we ever
trust polls again and the next
presidency to come well let's take that
first right so there's a sort of a
couple different issues here it doesn't
necessarily follow that a 63 percent
unfavorable polling for Donald Trump was
wrong because he won remember that when
it comes to the popular vote this is no
mandate for Donald Trump number one and
number two there are many Republicans we
know who hold an unfavorable view of
Donald Trump but voted for him because
they don't want Hillary Clinton
selecting three to four Supreme Court
justices because they believe Hillary
Clinton will do X Y or Z thing that they
don't like so just because Donald Trump
won this election electorally doesn't
mean that 63 percent of the electorate
does not have an unfavorable opinion of
Donald Trump did you know what I mean
yeah yeah yeah make sense what was your
other question okay another question is
um for me as being a I'm currently a
green card holder I'm a resident so uh
I'm doing it technically the right way
this is what Trump wants you want some
more people like need to come in to
potentially legally right and you're
working here legally I'm sure right
exactly yeah not like this whatever and
working illegally yeah good
exactly yeah so um obviously I have some
suspicions hopefully my city I'm already
been a resident for five years and a lot
supplies on my citizenship hopefully
like any months and now hopefully get my
papers in yeah but as I mentioned
currently live in
in LA I'm obviously very worried for
many other illegal immigrants legend
here today yes is it realistic in
European a what he promised on deporting
11 million which passed he said he
believes it even more than 11 million
yeah he thinks it could be 30 million no
I don't think it's really I don't think
it's realistic I mean remember Brett
deportations are up under President
Obama relative to george w bush and what
i what I believe Trump will ultimately
do on immigration and I'll if Pat or
Rachel disagree by all means let me know
I think we're going to see basically a
continuation of the Obama policy the
wall won't happen but we might see
fencing put up in some parts so that on
paper he can kind of claim victory on it
but of course Mexico's not going to pay
for it and I think we will see an
attempt to do at this I think you will
see at the state level more Arizona type
laws passed where you can be asked for
papers but I don't think we're going to
see anything close to what Trump has
promised on this do what do you think
Rachel asked for papers well so in a lot
of states you can't in a normal
interaction with police police can't
also inquire about your immigration
status and I think you could see it at
the state level laws change so that
police even if it's just you know a
traffic stop for example they could
demand proof of citizenship and I think
you could see some of those at the state
level what do you think I also kind of
think he's going to take more of a
hardline into preventing more
immigration as opposed to focusing on
deportation even though that's what he
said that's what I think and a lot of
that will come Pat probably from trying
to cut down on asylum and refugee status
applications those are going to be the
more likely mechanisms right I think the
wall is just not feasible and I think
even he is starting to back off of it
now but it'll be interesting I'm sure
deportations will go up but unlike Obama
he'll actually get the so-called credit
for it yeah and people will actually
recognize that that deportations are
going up great question I really
appreciate the call thank you
6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 is the number we are
taking calls on any topic that you want
to discuss of course heavily focused on
the election because we did have those
results this week who's on with me next
just tell us your name and where you're
calling from
my name is Jacob I'm from Arkansas
alright Jacob what's going on yeah I'm
wondering what the winds were Donald
Trump what does that say for the
American democracy for the future I'm
wondering what the America will look
like in about four years well so this is
an interesting question because we have
four years now of president elect Donald
Trump and we're sort of wondering how
much of what Obama did is Trump going to
undo what are we going to see in terms
of free speech in the Constitution what
are we going to see happen to the
Supreme Court which will have
multi-generational impact at the same
time we continue to recognize that the
president does not have absolute power
something Trump has been used to having
a CEO of his organization you don't have
absolute power as the president and that
could see him be significantly
frustrated and in addition to that the
country keeps changing and
demographically the country is going in
a direction that does not help can that
it's like Trump so I think we are going
to see an interesting four years in that
although the country electorally has
moved quite significantly to the left
particularly on social issues as well as
on some issues of taxation and the the
the connection between religion and
state we are also going to now see one
of the most radical administration's in
terms of what Donald Trump would like to
do and the question mark for me Rachael
is what will Trump be able to do which
is not going to match what it is that he
has promised or suggested during the
campaign well I'm really not sure I feel
like he's going to default a lot to Mike
Pence who is a lot more traditionally
conservative than he is and far more
dangerous oh and far more dangerous and
I think that that's something
interesting to remember is that Trump
wasn't necessarily driven by a far-right
ideology you know kind of on the bizarre
outskirts of that so I think it's a lot
of it is going to be left up to Mike
Pence the scariest thing to me Pat and
we're going to be doing a special on the
alt-right that segment producer Noah
Ferguson has been working on with me is
the emboldened ament's of society and I
am as I've said before as concerned
about that Jacob as I am about the
actual Trump policies are you worried
about that
right it's going to legitimize the whole
alt-right movement in this country I
would agree with Rachel I think for the
most part he's going to delegate out
responsibility we say he doesn't have
absolute power but he's gonna have both
houses of Congress and the Supreme Court
on his side so yeah pretty much as close
as you can get yeah we also have to
remember if we're thinking about this
kind of like a big business for instance
if this someone is coming in who doesn't
have a lot of experience and has a
temper
there are going to be people in place
and there are some intelligent smart
Republicans who are going to push back
on what he's doing
we better hope so better hope so Jacob
thanks so much for the call I really
appreciate it